[Musique]
Athlète total, il était si en forme et si
fort et si fort qu'il avait un pack de six, il faisait
un peu de musculation et il
travaillait sur un travail physique, il était en forme
[Applaudissements
] alors vous avez été appelé et il était
inconscient  il était inconscient à ce
moment-là et ne respirait pas
le dépôt SSI Sal Matata Corée du Sud Le
trafic Salman a demandé la configuration exacte Sugar
Chalet est une chaussure pour les membres du personnel
[Musique]
qui est pertinente pour les événements de bronzage ou de
souplesse sont des constantes traitement séparé
avec SS ou haute puissance  évacuer la chambre
je ne veux pas voir une autre famille
vivre ce que ma famille a fait Allah s
kanata d'accord la personne qui a fait ça un
occidental et elle n'a pas rencontré les eaux de
Lux API peut sembler paisible mais ce qu'ils
cachent est tragique avant cette nuit il  avait
été là presque tous les week-ends possibles,
y compris quand ils étaient encore de la glace sur
le sol et ouais il adorait ce
chalet
ce chalet est l'endroit où son fils Zachary
Mitchell passait du temps avec des amis en
été le lac à propos  À 70 kilomètres d'
Ottawa se trouvait son terrain de jeu.
Il avait l'habitude de plonger dans l'eau depuis le
balcon chaque fois qu'il venait. Il a fait ce
saut pas moins de 150 fois au cours des
quatre dernières années.
Zachary avait 21 ans plein d'énergie
et en pleine forme selon  le
coroner qui a regardé son dossier il adorait faire du
sport cette vidéo enregistrée par ses
amis le montre au lac il était un
poisson et il adorait sauter et il adorait
plonger et il était si doué ce
soir-là bien qu'il ait fait son saut habituel il le
fait  est remonté à la surface puis
aspiré
[Musique]
il n'a jamais refait surface Heather Mitchell
nous a raconté ce qui s'est passé dans les graves
questions que la tragédie a soulevées pour elle
pourquoi mon poisson mon petit poisson s'est noyé
il est un si bon nageur et
tout donc il n'y a rien qui
n'avait aucun sens j'avais besoin de savoir la vérité
Pascal Ghoulie est le coroner qui a été
chargé d'enquêter sur la mort elle
était déterminée à découvrir ce qui
s'était réellement passé
Zachary a bu un peu d'alcool mais pour
dessiner un co  L'inclusion de la mort par noyade
n'a pas, à son avis, révélé l'
image complète, mais le but des médecins du ski
, sauf de vous demander à quelqu'un de manger le
point de ski la personne T ordinaire cool
Casa Posse est une synergie eCornell EU
air d'élite de la connaissance si vite
ne pas  pleurez oh ne soyez pas un ketchup sont
une autre ville une autre histoire
Les fils de Jim Sheppard qui près de Toronto
semblaient aussi inexplicables quand c'est
arrivé
ils lui ont acheté un arbre commémoratif
devant l'arbre commémoratif planté pour
son fils de 15 ans il se souvient comment il
est mort  soudainement et sans avertissement Brian
Shepard était un adolescent athlétique ses
trophées de hockey sont toujours dans sa chambre
[Musique]
comme il le faisait souvent avec des amis Le
6 janvier 2008 Brian a participé au
tournoi de paintball mais ce jour-là
quelque chose s'est mal passé ils
attendaient le prix  cérémonie et un
dîner de l'équipe de la victoire quand quand il s'est effondré
puis il a été emmené à l'hôpital, il a fallu
l'hôpital et ils ont essayé pendant
environ quatre heures mais ils n'ont pas pu
c  corrigez l'arythmie et finalement son
cœur a abandonné
Jim Shepherd ne comprend pas comment son
fils est mort trois mois après sa mort il
est retourné là où c'est arrivé a dit
au propriétaire j'ai dit que cela n'avait aucun
sens la seule chose qu'un assistant était
caféine et il n'a pas bu de caféine
et c'est là qu'il m'a dit que je pensais que
tu savais et j'ai dit que je pensais que tu savais
quoi et la prochaine chose que je sais, c'est
que le Red Bull a traversé ce jour-là
et a distribué des échantillons de boissons énergisantes
et que Brian a été vu en train de prendre une
de ces boissons et de la boire,
son fils a bu du Red Bull pour Shephard,
c'était quelque chose de nouveau deux histoires une chose
dans les boissons énergisantes communes au cours de son
enquête,
le coroner Pascal Bulli a appris que
Zachary Mitchell avait été vu avec le même
genre de  boire juste avant sa mort
jaune soyeux c'est une victoire piscine rouge
tu n'es pas réveillé à la préparer noté
caféine un combat sim avec le 2qt casa
me
radicchio connais mon consommé le coroner a
découvert que  Zachary était porteur d'un
gène qui les prédispose à une arythmie
cardiaque
Zachary n'était pas au courant que l'
arythmie a été déclenchée lorsqu'il a
combiné l'exercice avec le son du taureau rouge,
tous contribuant et il y a des
appels de Paula à la bouée de fête du même homme,
je ne suis pas  me manger mauvais effet
Zachary a net sur le bas, ils ont l'air que tu es
quelqu'un est cinoiii Je dis toujours que je
soupçonne que la boisson énergisante a causé la mort de mon fils,
je ne peux pas le prouver, mais pour ce que
mon cœur dit, l'énergie était la
seule chose différente  ce jour-là que n'importe quel
autre jour de sa vie sportive et je
pense que cette boisson a contribué à
la mort de mon fils si ce n'était pas la seule raison pour laquelle
les boissons énergisantes sont différentes des
boissons pour sportifs qui sont riches en électrolytes et
réhydratantes, elles sont toutes si différentes
de pré  -des boissons mélangées qui combinent sucre
et forte teneur en alcool ces
boissons énergisantes qui ont récemment fait la une des journaux sont sucrées
elles contiennent de la caféine et d'autres
stimulants comme l'échinacée de guarana ou la
taurine c'est ce que Zach  ary et Bryan ont
bu juste avant de mourir sont leurs
histoires l'exception qui ne se produit que
dans des cas extrêmes, mais il y a de plus en plus de
recherches sur les effets indésirables liés à
ces produits
David Hammond, professeur et chercheur
à l'Université de Waterloo, a récemment
publié une étude sur les boissons énergisantes que nous
a constaté qu'environ la moitié de tous ceux
qui ont déjà essayé une boisson énergisante ont
déclaré avoir ressenti un effet indésirable
et vous savez qu'ils vont de légers à
graves, vous savez des choses comme des battements de
cœur certaines personnes signalent des nausées
vomissements plusieurs personnes ont signalé des
convulsions au Canada il y a  aucun moyen de
savoir si les boissons énergisantes envoyaient des gens à l'
hôpital
mais nous avons découvert que les centres antipoison
tiennent un registre des appels qu'ils
reçoivent pour des effets indésirables liés à
ces produits pour la première fois nous avons
rassemblé les données recueillies lors de ces
appels à travers le pays  sept provinces ont
répondu à nos questions nos chiffres montrent
que chaque année plus d'une centaine de
Canadiens appellent poison ce  nters pour des cas
liés aux boissons énergisantes et depuis 2012
il y a eu plus de 900 appels Merci
Deborah quelques points chauds sur document
bellossom cette exposition avec Emma Phu
notre nouvelle canette j'ai eu de pures nouvelles je joue
skc possible Connie Karen je poursuis ce
colis real mama like  Oh Samantha, nous
supposons que cela pourrait parler, c'est comme des
paroles sur l'efficacité associée au contact avec un échantillon de peau
aux États-Unis, le nombre
de visites aux urgences liées aux
boissons énergisantes a doublé, passant de 10
à 20 000 entre 2007 et 2011, mais
la cause de ces effets indésirables
reste  un mystère
[Musique]
ils ont la vingtaine et sont en pleine forme
le genre de personnes qui font de l'exercice quotidiennement
mais dans les prochaines minutes l'un d'eux
est sur le point de découvrir que les boissons énergisantes
ne sont pas aussi bénignes qu'elles le paraissent Jeremy
avait 20 ans Kathlyn  21 et Nikola 23
n'en ont jamais bu auparavant dans les quatre prochaines
heures, ils boiront une canette toutes les heures
[Musique]
dr.  François, il a enseigné son Brasa, a fait un
test similaire en 2012 sur quatre sujets. Il
s'agissait d'une recherche préliminaire afin d'obtenir
un financement supplémentaire. Ovilus est le plus
courant - l'épisode Thomas du semestre.
travail que vous n'êtes pas
parce que c'est ce que vous changez monsieur
car c'est là que LaGuardia Newark est une houle
des troupes italiennes sous moi à Tolède
nous fait qu'il a fallu cela, vous savez, ne dites pas Tony
face à mon citateur de caféine excellente
approche nous donnons une nouvelle priorité
nous  demander où se rencontre le triple plaidoyer, alors
j'espère que quelqu'un après avoir bu sa
première canette, la pression artérielle des étudiants a
augmenté Catherine se sent mal à l'aise,
sauf que plus désespérée vient de manquer
très clairement Shelley Waterloo après deux
canettes, elle est toujours mal à l'aise après
les troisième et quatrième canettes, ça ne fait
qu'empirer
juste ne regarde pas alors à côté de l'excuse je
suppose que j'ai dit la peur viens sur la sécurité
dixmoor pouvez-vous presser mon vient mon
argent résultats préliminaires de 2012
a révélé la tendance les sujets ont bu du red
Bull et du gourou dans les deux cas après quatre
verres leur tension artérielle a augmenté dans
leur sommeil a été perturbé ce que nous voyons
boku mystique Amanpour dans une peur constante est
déjà le manifeste pour moi comme vous
venez
rapporte donk Sandeep c'est Posey mais c'est
un  ce worgen, nous avons demandé
au gourou de la société montréalaise de boissons énergisantes de répondre à la
société sur ce CD, confondez votre swing,
monsieur, qu'une casquette dessa
continue de le produire a dit de confirmer une
particule que j'ai partagée et visionnée à un
instant un tireur d'élite à des occasions, elle a
mentionné une particule  la particule en colère
idée qu'il pourrait être passé sur
son potassium le gourou douteux
veut se démarquer de ses rivaux avec ses
boissons certifiées biologiques il n'est pas
surpris par ces résultats être humide
sentir comme un arc rouge sur parlé Gugu a
Moines café et carotte  garçon sur Zika gourou
dire beaucoup échantillon de preuve Asante
boule de carotte frappe de liqueur peraleda parti de
l'entreprise et catalyseur la plante
naturellement être vous le  re Susan
écoute longuement observer la merde nos sujets de test ne
boivent des boissons énergisantes qu'une seule fois médecin
car il est préoccupé par les gens qui les
boivent quotidiennement fan de moteur de dieu les évents est une
cérémonie comme un mécanicien
automobile l'acteur de defconn tant de garçons d'accord son
histoire qu'il connaît bien  a fait les manchettes
à Québec,
la jeune femme a été traitée par l'un des
dr.  collègues varughese, il dit que son
cas montre ce qui peut arriver lorsque vous
buvez quatre canettes par jour, tout comme dans l'
expérience, mais au quotidien,
le sous-verre de la ville d'une cacophonie anecdote
quadri dirigée vers nous Cipriano peut dire que
c'est mon droit que
vous ayez casona  ma star n'était pas bien debout
quand Brian est mort je ne savais
rien de je ne savais pas ce qu'était une
boisson énergisante tu sais qu'il y a
quelque chose là-bas qui a potentiellement
tué mon fils et pourtant je ne sais pas ce
que c'est après son  la mort de son fils Jim
Scheppers a estimé qu'il devait aller au
fond des choses nos enfants méritent une
approche de précaution
il a commencé à faire pression sur les politiciens et à
faire connaître les dangers associés aux
boissons énergisantes j'ai partagé mon histoire sur
Brian avec des gens et ils disent oh j'ai
essayé l'un des  ces boissons, je ne les réessayerai plus,
il
faut le signaler à Santé Canada
et la réponse, sauf pour un cas et
je parle d'environ 30 ou 40 personnes,
il n'y en a pas eu, mais il l'a fait. Jim Sheppard a
rapporté  son fils à Santé Canada
précisant que cela s'est produit après qu'il ait
bu une boisson énergisante cette information est devenue
accessible à tous les Canadiens sur un site Web
appelé Canada vigilance de 2003 à
2013 cent quarante-trois effets
indésirables, certains impliquant des enfants aussi jeunes que
8 ans étaient  rendu public, y compris 3
décès, donc Brian est l'un des trois
décès d'adolescents dans la base de données de Santé Canada et je
pense qu'il est très important que cela soit
documenté par quiconque à quel point c'était important
pour vous
que cela s'appelle la transparence et c'était
très transparent à l'époque il y
avait plus de rapports  lié aux
boissons énergisantes que toute autre chose, puis
tous les médicaments en vente libre combinés, par
exemple, il semblait donc qu'il se passait
quelque chose là-bas qui nécessitait
une enquête plus approfondie, c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles Santé Canada a réuni un
groupe d'experts en 2010 la finale  rapport
qui comprend 18 recommandations est
sans équivoque, ils recommandent que ces
produits soient traités comme un médicament et non comme un
aliment m  voulant qu'ils ne devraient pas être vendus
en vente libre, mais le
gouvernement conservateur a fait exactement le contraire en
réponse au groupe d'experts de
Santé Canada selon lequel ses propres études et
le gouvernement ont utilisé cette étude pour
justifier sa position,
nous avons contacté Samuel God WA, le directeur
général de Santé Canada.
Direction des aliments par téléphone, il est également
co-auteur de l'étude et il
croit toujours que c'était la bonne chose à
faire
malgré la décision largement
critiquée
aujourd'hui, les boissons énergisantes peuvent toujours être
achetées au comptoir et les
fabricants sont prêts à payer pour obtenir
leur  les boissons supportent la grande exposition, par
exemple un pain de taureau rijalallah ou le
système d'urgence de la poche à spaghetti depuis que
le changement de réglementation
Santé Canada a limité la
teneur en caféine à cent quatre-vingts
milligrammes, il oblige également désormais les
fabricants à ajouter des étiquettes d'avertissement
néanmoins les ventes de boissons énergisantes I '  ve
seulement augmenté deux virgule deux milliards de canettes
ont été vendues entre 2012 et 2017 sur
un autre vient sur un  très grande façon dont vous travaillez
unique merci non s'il vous
plaît presque si la mort à la télévision dunks
mais l'information sur les problèmes de santé
liés aux boissons énergisantes n'est pas aussi facilement
accessible c'est très difficile à obtenir après les
changements apportés en 2013
Santé Canada a cessé de publier les
effets indésirables liés à  ces produits, l'
industrie doit maintenant les signaler au
gouvernement, par exemple, si un
buveur de redbull subit un effet indésirable, il doit
maintenant le signaler à Red Bull Red
Bull doit alors le signaler au
gouvernement,
en d'autres termes, il est en partie
responsable de  se surveillant vous
regardez la boîte il n'y a pas de site Web
il n'y a rien là-bas nous sommes allés
avec Jim Sheppard alors qu'il essayait de signaler
la mort de son fils directement à Red Bull pas de
numéro de téléphone non ils veulent juste le faire
par e-mail donc il n'y avait pas de nom ou
tout ce qu'il n'y a personne il n'y a personne à qui
vous pouvez réellement parler pas à ce
stade c'est certain que
nous avons demandé aux plus grands fabricants du Canada
combien d'incidents ils ont signalés
depuis 2012, aucun d'entre eux n'était disposé à
nous donner une réponse,
sauf le gourou, l'entreprise dit qu'elle
n'a reçu qu'un seul rapport d'effet indésirable
consommateurs un italien
deux traités ici confusion
démontée nous sécurisons les données sur la
fois précédente nous ne connectons pas les données sangrahani
il a fallu  santé canada six mois pour
répondre à nos questions de 2012 à
2017 87 incidents de gravité variable
ont été signalés, y compris quatre décès
au-delà des trois qui ont été signalés
avant 2012, donc sept décès au total
santé canada ont refusé toutes nos
demandes d'entrevue Baskar sur notre copain
pauvre oui, je sais que c'est bas, je suis toujours perplexe,
nous pouvons prendre pour votre dernier
avec une place sur eux à un bas 23 mai
2019 au centre-ville de Montréal, le
défi d'arrêt au stand Red Bull bat son plein et
pacifie ne peut pas le manquer et si vous  Je ne le
connais pas, ce sont de purs étudiants Red Bull
d'une université locale qui s'affrontent
dans une simulation d'arrêt au stand, il y a beaucoup
de buveurs de Red Bull ici, c'est très
populaire sur le  campus et l'entreprise
n'hésite pas à distribuer des canettes gratuites
sur la tête tête tête tête pour venir
donner un pourboire à l'entraîneur concessionnaire dont nous seuls le
campus était complètement vraiment besoin d'une
photo simha Drita donc deuxième pista
professeur de marketing Jacques rien L a
enseigné à Vienne  L'Autriche, l'endroit où
Red Bull a été vendu pour la première fois en 1987, en
particulier à cet honneur de montrer -
Anna Mae Otto le quad Ricky bien sûr une
sauce froide au paddle ETS voir un bâtard malade
créer de grands événements c'est devenu une
spécialité de Red Bull l'entreprise autrichienne fait du
vélo partout  compétitions de ski et de plongeon
festivals de danse et de musique courses de patinage
jusqu'au saut de l'espace la recette est
si efficace qu'elle est copiée par
la compétition
aujourd'hui ils parrainent tous leurs propres événements
et les utilisent pour promouvoir leur produit une
étude canadienne récente a montré que 42%  des
12 à 14 ans pensaient que ces
publicités ciblaient des personnes de leur âge ou moins,
en d'autres termes, ce type de publicité
fonctionne sur les adolescents  voir les effets
c'est pourquoi les projets étaient SSE au spar
extreme ad est même mainstream kiss
cannibalize the cooler so tetrahedron de
la même manière qu'un profit Renato
l'auteur dit que les entreprises qui utilisent
ces stratégies savent exactement ce
qu'elles font je ne crois pas que
des adultes comme moi écrivent trop de
vélos BMX, vous savez et j'ai demandé à l'un des
représentants des entreprises de
me dire avec un visage impassible que ces
publicités ne plaisent pas aux enfants, il a eu le
courage de me dire avec un visage
impassible que c'était  Ce n'est pas le cas, mais je pense que le
bon sens et nos recherches suggèrent certainement le
contraire
et si vous dites que vous ne commercialisez pas auprès des moins de
12 ans, ce qui est difficile à atteindre, alors
assurez-vous que votre marketing pendant des années,
Jim Sheppard a collecté des exemples d'
enfants qu'il  dit qu'ils étaient des cibles de
publicité, il a transmis ses conclusions
au gouvernement en espérant qu'ils agiraient,
c'était vraiment conçu pour plaire aux
enfants, donc que ce soit intentionnel ou un
accident, ils ne sont pas suivis  En
vertu de la réglementation au Canada, il est interdit de
promouvoir ces produits auprès des enfants et
vous ne pouvez pas non plus prétendre implicitement ou explicitement
que ces boissons améliorent la performance physique. L'
Association québécoise des
médecins du sport s'inquiète également
Supposons que nous développions un laser.
bip lâche le costume
est sur les frères et sœurs d'une personne FN un monde AR +
YT Lib rapide car je contexte juste des
activités folles ont été enregistrées nos preuves
suggèrent qu'il se
passe des choses là-bas qui, à mon avis, sont
contraires à la réglementation ou au moins aux
principes et  les règlements à
Montréal lors du défi de l'arrêt au stand
redbull ont conclu un accord avec cette
université locale, il a qualifié la technologie de
supérieure comme un référencement génial juste
avant, mais lorsque nos caméras
sont apparues, red bull ne suivait pas les
règles, le personnel distribuait librement ses
produits  à tous ceux qui le voulaient en
ignorant l'accord qu'ils ont conclu avec l'
université, même les touristes sur le  la rue
a eu du Brésil nous avons demandé à redbull d'
expliquer
qu'elle est un papier d'affront de canard avant de faire
ce téléphone
mais ce n'est pas si simple quand nous
demandons une entrevue à Red Bull la société
nous a dit qu'elle n'avait pas de porte-parole au Canada
levena donc Louis même silliman shack
alina la renommée  Ilocano nous n'avons pas pu
trouver de porte-parole de Red Bull à Montréal
alors nous sommes allés à Toronto où se trouve le
siège social national de l'entreprise,
nous sommes allés avec Jim Sheppard qui voulait
parler à l'entreprise de ce qui était arrivé
à son fils sur le site Web de l'entreprise
il n'y a pas de numéro de téléphone  ou l'adresse Jim a
écrit un e-mail mais n'a jamais entendu parler de
ce bâtiment ici, ce serait tout ce
que nous regardons là-bas, celui en
verre que nous avons décidé de rechercher Red Bull en
ligne sur le site Web du commissaire des
êtres, il devrait donc être ici et
nous avons même
dans une rue commerciale du centre-ville aucun signe
et aucune trace de la présence de Red Bulls en
utilisant le suivi géographique, nos
smartphones nous ont conduits à ce parking
bingo oh o  kay je vois rouge bleu rouge les deux
mains
Je monte habituellement à l'étage ou est-ce
qu'ils savent en fait combien de fois un employé
du magasin voisin nous a indiqué une
porte indéfinissable que nous avions initialement
manquée c'est un grand pas nous sommes clairement
au bon endroit pour  Jimmy merci le
bureau est très branché et très occupé le
directeur des communications est venu nous rencontrer
oh salut Jim je suis toi les amis de Judy de l'
autre Canada oh tu as sûrement reçu mon
mail de Christina de Montréal ce
matin ouais ouais en fait parce qu'on
étions à Toronto et nous voulions
en fait rencontrer quelqu'un et elle a dit bien je
voulais juste vous présenter pour faire beaucoup
de tournage je peux vous quand nous nous sommes présentés
et avons posé des questions difficiles
redbull était principalement concentré sur une chose en
évitant notre caméra pourquoi n'étaient-ils pas
n'acceptez-vous aucune interview, aucune
demande faible que nous avons faite ou pourquoi Jim ne peut-il pas
parler à une personne réelle lorsqu'il
essaie de vous joindre Christina a
mentionné que personne chez Red Bull ne parle en
interne, mais pourquoi d'
accord si nous  éteignez les caméras
allez-vous répondre à nos questions d'accord d'accord
soyons de la famille que le reste
de la conversation s'est produit alors que notre
caméra était éteinte semble approprié alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a dit là-bas parce que
nous devons arrêter d'enregistrer à un moment donné
eh bien, d'après ce qu'elle m'a dit, je
pourrais contacter nos journalistes et
ils auraient la discussion avec moi.
Red Bull n'a jamais contacté Jim
Shepherd. L'entreprise a également refusé nos
demandes d'entrevue. Elle a renvoyé toutes les
communications à l'Association canadienne des boissons
.  mais eux aussi ont refusé notre
demande d'entrevue et nous ont dit que les
produits de leurs membres sont sûrs Heather
Mitchell ne se sentait pas à l'aise de
contacter Red Bull pour signaler le décès de son fils,
elle a plutôt écrit à l'
Agence canadienne d'inspection des aliments, l'ACIA,
qui est le seul moyen de le faire
officiellement signalé au gouvernement, je suis
même allé sur le site Web pour essayer de
signaler cela, je ne pouvais pas le comprendre
même si le coroner est venu à un clea  r
conclusion L'ACIA lui a envoyé un peu plus
qu'une déclaration générale le courriel que
j'ai reçu était plutôt étrange il
m'a adressé par mon prénom il m'a donné
l'énoncé de mission de l'ACIA
puis il a signé leur nom avec un
signé avec le premier  nomme ce que tu
étais, nous avons en fait signalé la
mort de votre fils non non non même pas en reconnaissant mes
préoccupations aucune reconnaissance du tout,
donc avec cette information, j'ai pensé d'accord,
ils viennent de me repousser pour une
organisation financée par l'
argent des contribuables qui a 6 000
inspecteurs
à ne pas  avoir le temps de donner suite à un
rapport de décès me semble profondément
problématique c'est la partie où
ils ont en fait essayé de déterminer qui
doit faire quelque chose
bill Jeffery est un avocat spécialisé dans
la politique alimentaire et nutritionnelle il a essayé de
comprendre ce qui se passe  lorsque l'ACIA
reçoit un rapport d'effet indésirable
comme celui que Heather Mitchell a envoyé pour
Zachary, tout comme nous, il a dû déposer une
demande d'accès à l'information et il a été
troublé par ce qu'il a vu dans un échange
de courriels après un décès signalé, les
responsables de l'ACIA ont remis en question la nécessité d'informer
Santé Canada, cela a révélé ce qui semblait
être un très faible niveau de curiosité et une
sorte de hâte de fermer les dossiers comme s'il
s'agissait de patates chaudes après  quelques jours de
discussions un officiel montait la
cantate 42 de la famille Concilio testée sur la
consommation wasanta Canada Darla
cuadrado hapa annuelle Lodge Ashkenazi et
surtout sur le diesel Amanda Papa's
window hypothese Esther SOT Canada
autrement dit le CFAA et Santé Canada
ne sont pas tenus de communiquer ils
viennent  m'a laissé me demander c'est une mort comme
ne voudriez-vous pas vous assurer que
la sensibilisation de Santé Canada vous savez
à la fin de la soirée de bal après la fin de la danse
les élèves du secondaire au Québec
vont souvent dans des campings pour continuer la
fête c'est une tradition avec un seul
règle tout va bien en juin 2019, notre équipage a
assisté à l'une de ces soirées, la plupart
des adolescents n'ont pas l'âge légal pour
boire de l'alcool, mais c'est  c'est une
occasion spéciale et ils veulent continuer toute la
nuit d'accord c'est long pour qu'il en
soit victime l'alcool et les boissons énergisantes
sont un mélange si dangereux que Santé
Canada exige maintenant une mention sur l'
étiquette ne pas mélanger avec de l'alcool dr.  Trask
est armé de mono d'accord maintenant je vois oh
attends je ne viendrai pas avec toi j'aime bien
c'est difficile de savoir exactement comment les
boissons énergisantes sont consommées beaucoup de ces
soirées post-diplôme ont lieu à Rawdon une
petite ville près de Montreux ironiquement
Rawdon est  une des soixante municipalités au
Québec qui ont interdit les boissons énergisantes mais
c'est surtout un geste symbolique les
évaluations des dégâts pour le joint Fiona
qu'ils ont trouvé autour voir tout fait en
concession d'autre part les provinces c'est comme
moi Astrid l'exposition au risque c'est coquin
ça n'arrête pas le dépanneur ou l'épicerie
les magasins de les vendre et il y a
beaucoup de clients Allah s kanata d'accord
la présomption mec ils disent Western
et Ximena l'industrie commercialise son
produit autour d'événements sportifs extrêmes ou de
scènes de fête les endroits où ces
boissons peuvent être mortelles les experts veulent
des réglementations plus strictes
ça s'appelle Amanda hey  Je suis bientôt le
dernier salami sur un passeport à pointe creuse à
la ProQuest, comparez-moi en supposant que les
pods que nous appelons sync Roumanie me laissent tomber
dep  se termine cher par louis cassis et
gère leur sensation économique beaucoup plus
après je suppose que
les adresses de Suzuki marketing particulier
dans les produits de base un spa alto pourrait l'
athlétisme sur le produit Polybe sinistre
sonne comme un kami merci de prouver cette
statistique de scie copiée athlétique
compétence réelle exacte encore de sur Noxubee  parlez
de la tragédie de dexter dont vous
réglementez un produit, une partie de cela est la façon dont il est
promu et annoncé aux personnes
qui peuvent influencer qui les utilise et comment
ils l'utilisent Red Bull n'a pas
et ne commercialisera jamais auprès des enfants
partout où le gouvernement  essayer d'interdire ou de
contrôler les ventes l'industrie est prompte à
contre-attaquer semble être il n'y a aucune
raison d'interdire ou de réduire la
restriction des boissons énergisantes ou des produits contenant de la caféine
aux enfants en 2018 le
Parlement britannique a tenu des audiences sur l'interdiction
des ventes de boissons énergisantes aux enfants de moins de 16 ans
le  l'industrie et leurs experts s'opposent à
l'interdiction, ils ont été interrogés par des députés sur la
question de savoir s'il y a
des avantages pour la santé  à travers votre produit pour
enfants
l'homme que vous voyez est un expert embauché par
monstre il est chez Intertek une
firme canadienne qui travaille pour de grandes entreprises
dont à une époque l'industrie du tabac
son nom apparaît même dans les
papiers de Monsanto vous si vous aviez un enfant de dix
ans  enfant seriez-vous à l'
aise à l'idée qu'ils consomment que
je ne vois certainement aucun problème à
consommer et à boire de l'énergie par opposition à
un café par opposition à du thé quand j'ai été
élevé ici au Royaume-Uni, ma mère m'a donné du
thé dès mon plus jeune âge en 2010
Les politiciens canadiens ont commencé le débat
sur la réglementation des boissons énergisantes cette
année-là et ont fait pression sur le
gouvernement canadien, mais nulle part il n'est dit qui
l'entreprise travaillait pour redbull a également fait pression
à l'époque et depuis lors, l'entreprise
a conservé un groupe de lobbyistes auxquels ils peuvent faire
appel à Ottawa vous  peut conduire une voiture
mais vous ne pouvez pas acheter par une boisson qui
contient également sous les premières lignes chaque fois que de
nouvelles réglementations sont proposées est l'
association canadienne des boissons qui  t il
n'y a pas de problème à mélanger de l'alcool
avec des boissons énergisantes lorsque Toronto a proposé d'
interdire la vente d'alcool et de
boissons énergisantes, l'Association s'y est opposée, il
n'est pas logique de dupliquer
les règlements existants appliqués par Santé
Canada concernant la formulation, l'étiquetage
et la commercialisation de ces produits à  un
niveau municipal J'ai entendu une fois de l'un de
nos plus grands bureaux de santé publique au
Canada que, lorsqu'ils examinaient des
règles sur la séparation de l'alcool et
des boissons énergisantes servies dans le même
lieu, ils n'avaient jamais été
aussi fortement sollicités que par la
boisson énergisante  entreprise, alors regardez, ils sont autorisés à le
faire, ils sont très bons pour le faire.
Je suis ici aujourd'hui parce que je suis préoccupé
par les effets néfastes sur la santé du
soi-disant projet de loi sur les boissons énergisantes contenant de la caféine.
Jeffery a plaidé pour une surveillance plus stricte
de l'industrie  mais Santé Canada a
été lent à réagir, je pense que c'est
ce qui se passe quand vous avez une industrie massive de
plusieurs milliards de dollars, il y a
beaucoup d'o  f la réticence à
vous savez opposer le système même s'il
cause du tort à des êtres humains individuels et
malheureusement j'ai vraiment le sentiment que les
profits de l'industrie et l'
influence de l'industrie et la prise de décisions sont là
aujourd'hui autant que cela l'a jamais été pour un
Jim Shepard c'est trop  tard, il est toujours
convaincu que les enfants ne devraient pas être
autorisés à s'approcher de ces produits. L'
industrie dit que ces boissons sont pour les
enfants, elles sont pour les adultes.
Santé Canada dit qu'elles ne sont pas pour les
enfants, alors pourquoi rendons-nous si facilement
disponibles, alors vous avez Connie le dire  cela
signifie par exemple qu'ils ne sont pas tous Sammy, elle a
probablement envoyé un télégramme à un
effet de spectacle lorsque vous mettez l'
installation de la province sur la zone de fête, donc même le gourou
ne s'oppose pas à une interdiction pour les enfants de moins de
16 ans voit la version ils disent que gossamer
goober roll affiches calendrier  Priyanka
dit que j'ai volé le casting d'un chiot Oscars
pantalon Pakistan sur un sermon Je t'ai rencontré frappé
un pop et ce n'est pas un dans de nombreuses
juridictions ont essayé de restreindre l'
accès bien qu'ils soient s  jusqu'à ce qu'il soit vendu sans
ordonnance dans cent
soixante-quinze pays, ce n'est pas une
corrélation directe entre cela et le
fait qu'un produit soit sûr ou non,
c'est statistiquement non pertinent si vous
ne considérez pas les résultats de tous
les déplacements à l'urgence  par exemple,
si vous ne considérez pas la mort de Zachary,
par exemple, Allah suppose que, comme esto es
que le descente, l'Académie décortique une table de télévision,
attendez que le
conjoint parte s'il y a une possibilité
que quelque chose qui est disponible gratuitement
sur le marché entraîne des décès,
nous devrions le savoir je  pense qu'il
y a plus de décès accidentels
là-bas qui n'ont pas été
soumis aux mêmes rigueurs que j'ai poussé mon
coroner le coroner de mon fils à
faire pour découvrir la vérité je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup plus de statistiques à
trouver quant à  Heather Mitchell, elle espère
que partager son histoire changera les
choses et conduira à plus de transparence
, c'est une si bonne personne qu'il signifiait le
monde pour moi
[Musique]
ed pour
rien sa mort aura un sens
[Musique]